[Music]
let's pretend that you're at the park
okay you're alone with your baby you
have nothing to defend yourself except a
stroller which is not only a great
weapon but it's also a great probe to
see what your critical distance is so
let's get a stroller out great and then
Asian baby whoa this is my Asian baby
baby that's just taller okay and Here I
am with a stroller why is the baby not
in the stroller because you wouldn't be
able to use that as a self-defense
weapon you don't want to use the baby as
a weapon so you're gonna use a strollers
weapon so when I'm taking my baby around
I will hold it and push an empty
stroller and precariat parts of town yes
okay thugs are gonna come at you
starting with jetson well who's this
what's he doing what do I do
oh sure one more guys coming right there
[Applause]
[Applause]
no no more they're dead he's a killer
okay excellent that was pretty good okay
that's pretty good pretty good no
brawling away okay so now we're gonna
take it up a notch if you're ready for
it but not up a notch that was that
maybe two notches okay so we're gonna
move over here this right
designated set for you this is a replica
of my home that's funny to you this
morning give you an idea of what you're
like in a regular home situation you're
a single father you're a good kid single
child I'm drinking beer alone
[Applause]
[Music]
like Al Bundy here all right
so take the take a moment and scan the
area to see what possible weapons you
can use as weapons for self-defense here
I'm gonna guess this axe is coming
there's always something off it's always
good to have an axe hanging around so
you just know what I'm hanging out with
my baby there's usually a beer and
hairspray you just turn all the way
[Applause]
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
fantastic that's right excellent
fantastic work I think I don't think
this helped anybody but it was a lot of
fun sure thanks Steven hallways
[Applause]